embora lapso ao observar a nossa guarda
no microscópio em 32 vai estar aí mas
não sou mágico
e agora o que é mas não conhecerem
alguém da netflix aonde nós vamos fazer
mais um vídeo de microscópio e como
podem ver pelo título pois vai ser muito
especial porque foi observado que o país
perde muito muito mesmo que é igual à do
windows está tudo bem o ano
ela está fazendo o melhor blog então não
é só essa zelda é igual à do irã e como
podem ver só alguns nós vamos observar o
guarani e não sou eu pra tudo isso mesmo
há muito tempo portanto vai aumentar a
escala hoje nós vamos tentar atingir os
presidentes orgulha 3215 parcialmente
nesta partida que tinha 31 vai lhe pedir
um bicho
a lista é muito melhor nesta partida em
pessoal esse é o real cuja batata
eu vou ficar olha aí ó e um pela lei
nanismo assim o ataque de ontem pelo meu
ela em todo o lado sem qualquer coisa
olhando aí não é não é só uma vez cada
um isto era um uso é o uso do urso é um
cara que planta 21 vai dentro mesmo
dentro do campo ou ali dentro que
rosinha e olha aí o sol incrível uma
coisa tão fina que tanto
é muito estranho a lei actual próxima
coisa antes grande nova iguaçu e
itaperuna é só observar o quanto mato
publicar eu vou estar podre em 21 linhas
com vários cursos ainda vai
eleito pelos muita pelo morto aqui
[Música]
o governo agora a pata dela em 321 vai a
lei a partir dela os olhares são minha
banca ela está sentindo muito bem
só vou tentar diz 12 mil e vamos ver o
que acontece
sumbe o pessoal olha aí eu ainda é muito
bacana eu vou tentar aproximar a equipe
da casa dela e tentar ver o olho aqui é
parte porque ela tem uma textura bem
diferente porque ela tem um instinto
jesus e se ouvir que ela acha assim
muito estranho está agora eu ir para o
méxico vamos sentar e sem falar muito
alto com o estado e para lá 31 vai
tentar aproximar agora na zona do
pescoço dela porque tem muitas coisas
lindas ac3 não vai aí ela tenha uma
papel vinha do bairro não sei bem o que
quiser mas vamos tentar ele também é que
tem muito mais textura bem ainda é muito
bem da série agora em 321 vai muito além
dela há um claro movimento que tomei uma
cópia é porque eu não ia pôr lloret e
busca nela inea já acabou a nossa
instituição em laguna jácomo ok só vou
deixá la em paz agora
embora
[Música]
e uma rainha muito medo mas vai observar
a arquitetura porque sabe cantar
chateado nem está muito quieta e voilá
do trabalho de luta pessoal em 32 [ __ ]
vai ainda passa toda sua textura bem fiz
só isso não sou eu que continuo
microscópio está fugido na década de 90
uma papel e bora lá 321 vai calma voltei
é só observar um clean olhar bateu bem
estar em casa não me colocando a lei
muito estranho este tipo pedra julian
lei que recebeu toda a textura da peruca
tipo pedra é muito louco mas eu não
deixo mesmo olha olha é unha é o anjo
lente união dentro da lei
eu juro a lei é muito bom que só não
conseguiu precisar muito bem em portugal
é porque ela estava sentindo muito e eu
acho que já tava evitá-la é eficiente
confortável tempo não vou continuar
noite deixei alguns comentário com
tostão e passa pelo canal aqui numa
alegre é e substituir vão deixando a
equipe de montevidéu tão bom e já falam
só aqui do nosso lado vamos manter dois
mil estão provavelmente não viram e aqui
mas vocês podem saber aqui no canal da
safra em lei e nem só por quem vai até a
próxima